all right now we turn sorry don't blame
the messenger to the not so good news
all right earlier today the massive
three-quarters of a point rate hike from
the fed now this is the third increase
uh from the fed since joe biden took
office goldman sachs for example
predicts in the next two years as many
as 11 maybe more anyway three so far
many more expected and as inflation is
draining the savings and retirement
funds uh you're all watching it you're
all seeing it donald trump predicted it
it's hurting americans all across the
country especially the poor the middle
class people on fixed incomes two-thirds
of americans are now living paycheck to
paycheck sadly rate hikes are not good
for for example property values to put
it mildly let's break down what this
rate hike means for example now under
donald trump in 2020 many americans they
were getting mortgages with interest
rates around three percent some even
lower in the twos at the i'm talking
about a 30-year fixed rate now if you
bought a 400 000 home let's say you put
20 down your monthly payment on a
30-year loan would be
nine hundred ninety three dollars a
month at the end of thirty years the
total mortgage paid with interest you
bought a four hundred thousand dollar
house it would be four hundred and
eighty five thousand six hundred dollars
now you go a half a point or half a
percent increase in interest rates your
payment goes up by a hundred dollars and
the total payment paid over thirty years
goes up by thirty two thousand another
half a point you're looking at a two
hundred dollar increase every month and
a sixty four thousand dollar hike
altogether
that's at four percent interest now
prior to today a 30-year fixed mortgage
was averaging uh or well 6.3 some odd
percent at that rate your monthly
payment is 500 more than it would have
been in 2020 and the total amount that
you would pay over the course of your
loan would be 203 000
wow now today it gets a lot worse rates
now expected to go as high as 7.5
percent let's take a look at buying that
same home that means if you compare the
rates in 2020 under donald trump well
you'll pay a thousand dollars more per
month and after today's hike and
interest rate
or interest rates going up you'll spend
a whopping 320
000 more dollars over the 30-year course
of your loan after today the same price
you would have only paid for what a year
and a half ago
i mean it's unbelievable it's staggering
now at these rates that means purchasing
a home now is going to become
unaffordable for many americans if not
most americans that means sales of
existing homes that's going to plummet
you know the day and age you put a house
on the market 15 people come in people
are bidding above asking price those
days are now going to end except for
maybe states where people are moving to
like florida texas tennessee and the
carolinas but for most states your home
values will plummet new home
construction will come to a screeching
halt that's going to kill contractors
fewer and fewer americans will refinance
their homes and guess what your property
values that you've been looking it's
been rising the last numbers a year
number of years that like your stock
market and your 401k that will plummet
in fact they are already going down as
we speak this will not only impact the
housing market but also america's
financial institutions we're headed
straight for a recession even as
inflation continues to climb now this
week we also learned that the producer
price index this measures wholesale
prices that businesses pay and then you
pay more on top of it it's up a whopping
10.8 percent if you watch this program
you know the driver of these costs is
record high gas prices and diesel prices
joe biden could work to bring those
prices down right now and don't take my
word for it let's listen to kevin
o'leary cnbc take a look
the economy the market
they're not it's not going to be able to
recover unless we see some relief and
relief that we can believe is a
long-term solution for oil
here's how you fix that problem it was a
polymer policy mistake by biden when he
came in you reverse the mistake all you
have to do is jawbone the oil market's a
futures market just announced you're
going to license three new refineries on
the east coast also announced we're
going to re-examine the the xl pipeline
we're going to give back the leases in
anwar we're going to give more carbon
direction to understand what the costs
are all of those policy mistakes could
be reversed by just getting up and job
owning it you could take oil down below
100 bucks if you got more accommodative
towards the future production now biden
may not do that that's on him
bingo but biden's not going to do any of
that because the radical climate
religious cult that runs the
administration won't let him democrats
new green deal party democrats
socialists they won't let him instead
biden sent a very mean threatening
letter to oil companies demanding they
stop taking a profit because it's a
patriotic thing to do um joe they have a
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders joe but keep this in mind
anyway despite the administration and
they're demonizing and blaming anybody
and everybody but themselves well and
they're going after the oil giants let's
look at companies like exxon mobil their
profits are flat over the last quarter
and in 2020 guess what joe many of these
companies lost money they made no profit
at all but you're not going to hear that
from the administration because they're
just looking to scapegoat they'll blame
putin they'll blame trump they'll blame
oil companies they'll blame meat
companies they'll blame poultry
companies so let's be very clear joe
biden caused this problem he caused it
because of
his election promises he told you and
promised every american this is what he
was going to do i will remind you again
so you never forget it and you can tell
all your friends take a
stop
look
fuels
we're all dead doing away with any
subsidies for fossil fuels number one
number two holding them liable
for what they have done particularly in
those cases where your underserved
neighborhoods and you you know the deal
okay and by the way when they don't when
they're deliberately put them in jail
kiddo
i want you to just take a look okay you
don't have to agree but i want you to
look in my eyes
i guarantee you i guarantee you we're
going to end fossil fuel and i am not
going to cooperate with them okay would
there be any place for fossil fuels
including coal and fracking in the biden
administration
no
we would we would work it out we would
make sure it's eliminated
of course his promises didn't stop there
biden also vowed to treat saudi arabia
like a pariah country directly accusing
the crown prince of being responsible
for the death of journalist jamal
khashoggi and now lo and behold joe
biden's headed over to saudi arabia to
meet with the crown prince where our
president i bet pretty much every every
penny i had he's going to grovel on his
hands and knees and beg the crown prince
to pump more oil all because the
religious climate
alarmist cult and the democratic party
won't let him produce
oil gas domestically it's that simple
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else